[Music]
Michael Bennett just joined just some
Seahawks and uh I gave him a full plate
here of barbecue
now can you handle that is that too much
barbecue here hurry I'm not really red
meat or so these days so no you're not
no no I'm on my sushi guy Wow doc
getting applause would you want
headphones yeah I can't hear you guys
okay there's headphones right breakdown
that's all guy right here here's her his
job right there is headphone guy new
headphones wait wait rich husband's over
here stealing sorry real rich put that
down rich Nilsen bar we got high
cholesterol already I want to see your
TV for at least two more minutes
welcome to the final hour here Deion
Sanders will join us coming up we'll get
to your phone calls will least try to we
just talked to Pat McAfee who at the age
of 29 announced his retirement I'm not
surprised you're not surprised at
Maccabee retired at 29 as a punter no
I'm not how come now take some people
just exciting to get tired of doing the
same thing over over and over and over
again do you think that you'll just one
day wake up and say that's it does
Marshawn did it yeah you think you'll do
that Jim Brown did it Bobby will do it
it's not Barry Sanders did it I mean
it's just not it's not uncommon I think
a lot of people feel like because they
feel like his job is a special job why
would you ever leave their job but
sometimes just so people would have a
beautiful wife and you like why do you
beat that wife so is that one of those
things or sometimes just get tired of
doing what you've been doing for a while
you want to try something different he
wants to know evolve so I respect it
what do you want to do when you're done
what I want to do when I'm done I'm not
I like traveling of course I want to do
more even more work in the community
maybe have my own TV show I figure if
you can do it and absolutely you know
the rest of the guys can especially if
skip can do is give a listen no you're
right than anybody like I can do it you
know me he's living a good life my
casket can do it did I have goals but
but can you throw out those hot takes
though yeah like give me a hot take what
you mean hot take
get strong opinion I give stronger
things what do you want to try to pee
something like like Schiphol say LeBron
is overrated or something or he's not
the best player in basketball or
something like that baby right now
oh no no no or he'll just say something
like Tim Tebow should still be playing
in the NFL well Tim Tebow should not be
stifling everybody maker
it seems he was great on TV when he's
not talking did you play against very
good paper tears yeah I just get to talk
I took my wife with you actually finally
how about you and your wife do a show
yeah we would really fun to be fun but
when it comes to giving strong you're
not afraid you were your brother no I'm
right right yeah I think to give
opinions you can't really care what
people say you can't be like on your
Twitter worried about how people
perceive you or stuff like that you got
to be able to take the heat I think I
could take the heat
how much will you talk to your brother
this week I'll talk to him every day all
day I'll just you know keep him going
tell them not to get too you know too
caught up in all the stuff that's going
on because after you win you can get to
be a champion for a whole year so you
get to party every day could you be a
patriot not only keeping see home nobody
could you fit in with listen with the
Patriots I don't know oh yeah
considering with a pitch I consider
anywhere I'm a likable guy everywhere I
go I've been like but are you allowed
you wouldn't be able to speak your mind
with the Patriots I can speak my mind
anywhere I go well then maybe the
Patriots wouldn't bring you in because
they'd be worried you'd speak your mom
nah they wouldn't be where if I speak my
mind because Belichick speech is mine no
he does exactly but not speech and he
doesn't care so it was like he's
speaking his mind he doesn't really want
to answer to anybody why does he need
answer he's a champion
is there a philosophy to what you say
when you say it or is it just
spontaneous this is the truth is my
truth that's the most important thing is
my opinion it's how I feel so it's me so
it's not like I'm going out trying to
give you a calculator answer what I
think you what I think I should be
saying how everybody would like me to
say I said the way I feel like it needs
to be said and that's all I really care
about
I remember pre-gaming the Super Bowl
against the Patriots you
meant with your cowboy hat on didn't you
yeah yeah like what was the the cowboy I
was one of my one of my best friends and
his dad was one of my best friends he
died from cancer and that was his
favorite hat
and I told him I told him that you know
dad stay with me since you know since I
started playing football and I want to
give him a chance to see me playing the
Super Bowl so I was bored ahead he's he
passed away so I want to give an
opportunity to be on the field the wind
that you had this Super Bowl stays with
you how long the loss in the Super Bowl
stays with you hello they all last as
long as you wanted to last which one
lasted longer we are less than equally
as long no Allah I did the champ the
championship left over to when the
season started and the loss and when I
went to the seasons party you held on to
that the main what do you think with
that law how tough was it then metals I
don't know I've never held anyway I feel
like you go into the game with the
opportunity to know that there's a
possibility that you can lose that's
possibly that you can win and you can't
let let your job a sexual regular life
is like what if I go home I'm like my
white daughter I'm talking I'm like no
I'll officer no I'm not being a husband
today we lost last week it's like no I'm
not doing that so it's like you still
gotta you still got to live your life
this is just the game I think people
love it so much but it's still just a
game I and I was watching you in
particularly with Russell I didn't think
the Patriots had an answer to him but
defensively they did not have an answer
to you and you know I wanted to say it
to you when I watch I thought you were
the best player in the Super Bowl yeah
and you're not surprised you a drink I
agree I agree with all my greatness
how great is is Brady I understand Brady
is the best of all time what makes him
or when did he become the best of all
time I think he always thought he was
the best of all time so he approached
everything like the greatest and look at
his accomplishment
man the guy missed four games he do two
interceptions yeah 30 touchdown passes I
mean over 4,000 yards passing I mean but
you guys beat him into it we did beat
him but we didn't beat it wouldn't be
Matt Ryan
we're gonna get inflation again who was
who had a better better - better offense
I don't know both teams great I mean who
would you rather face again
I read the face both of them well you
got a pick between already Facebook
because I love hitting Tom Brady but I
also like hitting Matt Ryan but then I
like hitting Drew Brees
you know I kind of like hitting Aaron
Rodgers and in this Cam Newton and then
Showtime I want to hit Russell Wilson
but I'm never really get a chance to
Libby's once in a while I come by be
like hey you everyone ever seen just the
face you going mu student unrest is
Michael Bennett of the Seahawks the
defensive end
and he joins us on behalf of black Santa
clothing line no Black History Month
they changed it I'm here because of
black history oh you are yeah okay well
sometimes when I came out today so Black
History Month and black Santa clothing
line no gender fantasy writers -
lancashire what would you like to tell
us about Black History Month I'll just
tell you about all the great
accomplishments that we've had over this
this time period and it was cool to have
a month to be able to recognize the what
we've done for in American history I
think you know with now in school they
don't talk about the stuff that happened
you know they talk about you know just
you know they talk about Beyonce for
blackish you might they'll talk about
the Rosa Parks and you know there's
ought to be wells and all these guys
Marcus Garvey's talk about that they
don't talk about Beyonce I went I
thought I taught black history month at
my daughter's school because of the what
they were teaching I came up there and I
was like what this is not this is not
and you know after a while when I was
teaching with the kids they started to
realize how much how much touched and
reach that we've done for America and
think that we have created
you know we how we may turn this country
into what it is we didn't get we don't
get a lot of our recognition that we
deserve and I think you know going into
black you see - another month to
remember all the things that we've done
you know there's a lot of talk about the
social injustice that we have that we've
dealt with does there's a lot of that
but there's also the creation that we
have done the scientist and all the
things we've done so it's really cool
and travelers and it's just a good month
to really talk about the things that
we've been by the way beyonce is I'm
pregnant with twins with Casey she's
pregnant
yeah
yes there you go I told you something
about Black History Month in Black
History Month
my name's I Cristiano with Beyonce by
the way during the commercial we do it
yeah Polly we want to make your dream
come true Michael
that you've always wanted to sack
wrestle Wilson yeah we
McLovin one of our guys he's right next
to you he's gonna wear this Russell
Wilson Jersey and Allah yes
yep for that would you what can I kick
him in the nuts is that [ __ ]
absolutely we encourage it are you are
there kids
yeah all right is good you can right
here it's a song for you bad this was
for you
his lactic technic fake yeah this it's a
it's a new type of birth control he's
given us there we go yes yes the job
that I can do he can kick people who
none kick people at night you can hire
him I won't have kids that package could
you guys see yourself being an actor
yeah I think so like an action hero or
something yeah I could be or look
villain villain I mean Michael strain
could do it I think I could do it Greg
that's pretty good news I'm not saying
he's my god so he can do it yet because
the van I think there's a chance that I
can do yeah but you you mean you got
natural natural ten I got natural beauty
right you got an ex-wife kills with a Z
what you got skills
it's funny how people spell stuff and
Enki be spelt in any kind of way and
they'll say that it means like I'm like
that is not fake it less like you
whatever they write you have to agree
with what they write almost like that's
not true do you ever challenge reporters
on what they write I challenge reporters
all the time because I feel like
sometimes reporters they don't really
know what it takes to get to that point
in the game like they'll actually dumb
questions like how does it feel to lose
what was it like to lose
losing sucks and it's like you know they
try to pray and pick at you and you have
to go be able to have a great roberto's
form I think sometimes the organization
NFL they think it bothered by my
responses but to me it's just like
they're actually a question I'm
answering the question the way I want to
answer it so if you don't like you find
me and if they find me how much should
be been fun find I don't know and do
they send a bill to or they take out
your paycheck they take a letter
paycheck you know you know they ain't
giving me a joke okay yeah
if Donald Trump does have to pay tax and
he no I whenever he's a Michael Bennett
joining us on behalf of Black History
Month we're going to make his dream come
true he's not allowed to hit Russell you
can't even read them on Russell Wilson
and brento one to a billion I had a grow
up I was like look so look I my kids
like private school look at you have you
hit Russell Wilson or get close to them
I'm gonna kick you in the nuts
that's disgusting telling today yes
mclovin can I run around and scramble
like Russell knows I can kick you in the
nuts dance raise you up committing us
McLendon a [ __ ] they don't want me at
for kids I know something me on Sanders
set to join us Michael joining us on
behalf of Black History Month and the
Bennett Foundation yeah the beneficient
that's the greatest foundation of course
it was because it's cool is because one
of the things now where I go out I do a
lot of things with kids or food and
gardening and programs like that because
there's so many kids in the inner cities
that don't know about the vegetables
this times I bring kids to my events and
I asked them what a tomato is and they
don't even know to what a real tomato
looks like and I'm just like we're
already writing ours this America right
now but kids are so far removed from the
wet to eat and how to eat and the
families don't know how to shop in this
I mean as a athlete sometimes I feel I
almost feel like we are marketing things
that we should be marketing because kids
are really following what we eat and
then when we go on there and say that we
eat em work can sell em workers you I
don't know if your sponsor bond
the N word them em you know not the N
word what I said the M word right house
I thought you know no I'm not sponsored
by them I thought it was Black History
Month and you were saying that and I
didn't know what you were saying
not like McDonald's I said oh well you
know like because you are saying as a BM
words the M or MacDonald yeah no we're
not sponsor know obviously you know
sometimes I use a Apple you you eat the
shoto kids that you eat those things and
kids want to eat like you eat so it's
like and you know most athletes don't
eat like that they all have private
shelves today you know they measured at
Mills I so I feel like sometimes there's
a athlete we're leading the kids down
the wrong path and I feel like we're my
foundation I'm trying to leave you kids
down
right path about how to stay healthy I
mean so many kids in them these days
kids are dealing with childhood obesity
it's like this at five years old this
kid has diabetes it's like how does that
how does that happen it's like the food
every eater the choices that we're
making it's just terrible these days
keep stirring it up and I appreciate
yeah I will thank you so much
you want to stick around and smack
McLovin long as I keep coming up yes
works again Michael Bennett CR the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
[Music]